alors donald trump est il selon vous
rattraper son retard avec joe biden il
est sûr que tout le monde veut savoir
qui va gagner et ce qui s'est passé en
2007 2016 est vraiment une leçon il faut
comme l'a dit votre reportage fois s'il
en faut pas vendre la peau de l'ours
avant de l'avoir tué les sondages certes
dit ce qu' il est il dévisse mais on ne
sait pas ce qui va se passer il ya une
expression aux états unis qui est la
surprise d'octobre il est possible qu'en
octobre
un des deux candidats ou les deux
candidats sortent une affaire très
importante qui dont l'objectif sera de
changer l'opinion d'une grande partie de
la population donc il faut faire très
attention
déjà très bas s'est présenté comme
l'artisan de l'accord entre israël les
les états arabes unis donc ils essayent
de regagner du crédit
en politique étrangère il est possible
que les démocrates une information
catastrophique vague et s'en sortir en
octobre
donc il faut vraiment se méfier
actuellement la gestion du coc vite qui
effectivement très mauvaise d'etats-unis
sens plutôt militer pour une défaite de
temps mais les chiffres s'améliorent
légèrement pour le coc vide
il est tout en bas 40 % n'a toujours pas
dévisser donc il faut faire très
attention et équipe est justement après
cette crise sanitaire à la crise
économique
les multiples violences dans le pays
quel programme et quels quel bilan peut
t'il à défendre alors dans les fêtes les
politistes intéresse au programme
mais ce qui va déterminer l'élection
c'est un récit et essaye de vendre un
récit sur lequel ben hayden serait
l'otage de l'extrême gauche ce qui te ya
la pure imagination mais qui va faire
mouche auprès de certains partisans
d'autre part il ya un problème dont très
peu de médias parlent qui est hyper
importante pour l'élection c'est le
problème des radiations opéré par le
parti républicain
radiation des lecteurs qui se chiffrent
à plusieurs millions selon le
journaliste spécialiste de cette affaire
qui s'appelle break par l'est donc en
fait c'est une forme de triche qui est
en marche depuis longtemps mais qui
s'est accélérée depuis 2016 et si les
électeurs qui disent qu'ils vont voter
pour bananes sont empêchés d'aller voter
il est évident que sera un impact sur
l'élection il ya énormément de facteurs
incertains et qui dépend très peu des
facteurs objectifs le seul facteur
objectif qui est vraiment très mauvais
pour tout homme c'est la gestion de kobe
pour le reste on est dans un combat de
récits avec des incertitudes sur ce qui
va sortir dans les deux mois qui
viennent
est-ce que là la position d' outsider
qu'a toujours eue donald trump peut
jouer en sa faveur pour ses prochaines
élections voilà il n'est plus un
tailleur piste il est le président dont
il est par l'état est responsable ou
vécu comme responsable de ce qui se
passe donc il a c'est une carte en moins
il a cette fois ci maintenant on ne sait
pas du tout si les débats avant bras
lieu et comment ils vont évoluer
ça sera certainement un impact donc
aujourd'hui tous les médias dominants
envie de dire ça y est il est battu il
fonde compagne du reste contre lui mais
l'expérience devrait conduire à se
méfier de ce genre de de pronostic
quel cap pourrait obtenir selon vous
jusqu'en novembre pour espérer un
nouveau mandat alors peut s'attendre à
un déferlement de xénophobie ou cette
fois-ci john va jouer l'opposition à la
chine avec eux qui sait peut-être que sa
surprise d'octobre ce sera un mini
conflit avec la chine plus ce qu'il a
déjà annoncé une présentation totalement
tendancieuse de bayonne qui est
quelqu'un qui est très adroite omettant
lauda l'otage de l'extrême gauche
laquelle extrême gauche évidemment peu
importante en termes de voix d'affluence
aux états unis donc voilà les deux cas
il va jouer
merci beaucoup pierre galand d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes professeur de
civilisation américaine merci à vous